happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday day of the dead
what you don't know what dave the devs
is day of the devs is the greatest and
definitely the oldest independent games
festival that exists it was started over
10 years ago by double fine productions
and i made it to celebrate uh the best
independent games out there and bring
them to you the fans we want to bring
developers and players together to get
together play games and have a great
time it used to be a physical event only
in san francisco but now it has gone
digital so the whole world can enjoy it
and we're really excited this year to be
part of uh summer game fest
so sit back relax put on your party hats
this thing i'm supposed to put this on
that's right everybody
put on your party hats
everybody
everybody
that's right that looks good now we're
cooking
put on your party hat
and enjoy day of the deaths
[Music]
we got a new one today this is from a
good friend michael frey and rafael
munoz previously michael made a game
called kids with playables that we
published at double fine presents and
this is his new one it's about the
limited time we have on earth told
through the life of a fly this is called
time flies
[Music]
hello everyone
my name is michael
you might know my work from a game
called plug and play
i co-founded
a company called playables where we made
a game called kids
but today we're gonna talk about this
guy
in my upcoming project
that is a collaboration with
rafael munoz who is the principal
programmer on the game the project we're
collaborating on is called time flies
[Music]
[Music]
time flies is about our limited time in
this world in switzerland where i'm
right now we have a life expectancy of
maybe
84 years in the us it's about 77 years
so you have a little bit less time to
achieve the things you want in your life
[Music]
uh
[Music]
in time flies the things you can achieve
are nicely prepared on a bucket list
this is a very small part of that bucket
list
so these are the things you can do in
the world
[Music]
so
[Music]
the game is coming to playstation
nintendo switch
pc and mac
sometime next year
please visit
timeflies.bus
where you can
sign up for the newsletter
so you get updated when it's out
or you find a link to the steam page
where you can wish list again
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bye
[Music]
our next game is planet of lana the
debut title from sweden based wishfully
studios and published by thunderful
publishing the gameplay is reminiscent
of dark side scrollers like inside and
little nightmares but the vibes could
not be more different
who are these enigmatic enemies
what do they want with lana's sister and
her world and what other secrets are
there to uncover in this beautiful
boundless environment
hello my name is adam juanyus and i'm
the creative director at wishfully
we're a small indie game studio in
sweden making planet of llama
in our game you play a young girl called
lana who is forced out on a mission to
save her sister that has been taken away
by an invading robot army
early on in the game lana meets the
mystical creature maui
you quickly develop a strong bond and
friendship to maui and she proves to be
both intelligent and loyal
[Music]
being her own personality movie also has
things that she's afraid
of but being small and agile also has
its advantages for example being able to
reach places that you can't
[Music]
she also has this special ability she
can use to control some of the strange
creatures of this planet
[Music]
together you have to make it through
both the harsh and beautiful
environments of noble
past dangerous robots
through deep and cold caves
unraveling long forgotten mysteries
that all lead to your destined future
[Music]
planet of lana is really a labor of love
and we're very excited here at wishfully
to bring you what we believe is a truly
unique adventure and beyond the
companion-based puzzle solving and
hand-painted art style you will
experience an engaging story with twists
and turns that hopefully will stay with
you long after the credits have rolled
planet of lana is coming to xbox and pc
this year and you can wish list right
now at steam or sign up at our
newsletter at planet oflana.com
this next title from two star games is
quite literally an on-the-rails shooter
you and your little yellow train with
its mounted machine gun and exquisite
collection of bobble heads will face off
against a demonic clown-faced train who
is hell-bent on devouring human flesh
this is choo-choo charles
hey i'm gavin i'm the solo developer
behind two star games and i'm currently
making choo choo charles
[Music]
it's an open world horror game where you
navigate an island in an old train
[Music]
upgrade over time and then use it to
fight an evil spider train named charles
if you pump enough lead into his face
that'll probably encourage him to run
off and find something else
you have one goal above all else and
that's to summon charles to a 1v1 and
fight him to the death
to do that you'll need to explore the
open world looting abandoned areas and
completing missions for the locals to
gain powerful new weapons and scraps
that you can use to upgrade your trains
speed armor and damage
there because it might be unwise to
wander too far from your train
if you do encounter charles while you're
roaming around it doesn't matter what
you do now because you have
if it sounds like something for you be
sure to follow and wishlist choo choo
charles on steam i'd greatly appreciate
it really does mean a lot
we've got a special one for you it's
very personal and near and dear to i
make it because it's a i maybe presents
published title it's called escape
academy and think of it like hogwarts
but for escape rooms it's from developer
coin crew games and they hail from the
arcade amusement space they've designed
escape rooms in real life better they
talk about their game than me here they
are
hey i'm mike
i'm wyatt and i'm michelle the art
director
wait am i supposed to say i'm the
hey i'm mike i'm wyatt we're the
founders and i'm michelle the art
director oh okay this is the i hate that
all right once once more with feeling
hey i'm mike i'm wyatt and i'm michelle
and we're coinker games
[Music]
when coin crew games was founded uh we
were actually building real world escape
rooms and arcade machines but when the
pandemic hit we needed to pivot so we
decided to take those learnings building
real world escape rooms and transpose
them into a digital format unless escape
academy was born
[Music]
good luck trying to hack me without
sufficient power probability of your
expulsion hi escape academy is an escape
room adventure game that you can play
either single player or co-op
you play as a student at this titular
mysterious escape academy where you get
to master the art of puzzle solving and
train to become the ultimate escapist
what are you waiting for a room full of
gas is no place to relax
we're all fans of escape rooms so when
we couldn't find a digital authentic
escape room experience we decided to
make one ourselves
walls are often misleading at the
academy
escape academy isn't just a puzzle game
it's an escape room game and it brings
that play pattern home we have a huge
amount of puzzles in this game and they
never repeat and in addition to that you
can solve every puzzle using just your
mind no dexterity required although you
may want to bring a paper and pencil
[Music]
the academic theming gave us the
leverage to create a wide variety of
rooms that support the narrative and put
players in situations they would never
find themselves in real life escape
rooms
when we were designing the game it was
really helpful to have
the experience of both playing a lot of
escape rooms and designing real world
escape rooms as sort of a
design anchor to buoy us to
[Music]
i did not anticipate the rodent
assisting you
bad tumeric
sadly that rat will be no help in
bypassing my lasers we really took our
time to create an eclectic cast of
students and faculty members that helped
guide you throughout the academic
journey of escape academy
building on the lessons that you get in
each room and raising the stakes
throughout your journey at the academy
was definitely a design pillar we wanted
to make sure it came through in the
final game
i am not not feeling so well
analysis i have succumbed to
disco fever
escape academy is coming to xbox
playstation and pc on july 14th and will
be available day one on xbox game pass
and you can wishlist us today on steam
we'll see you at the academy
thanks escape academy
this game's for all those fans of
organization out there all those
organizers it's from a studio called max
inferno and it's a game about getting
things lined up just right
it's called a little to the left
[Music]
hi i'm annie hi and i'm lucas
and we are max inferno
yep we're really excited to share with
you today a cozy puzzle game that we've
been working on called a little to the
left
[Music]
a little to the left is a game where you
sort stack and tidy up the house
in each level puzzles are hidden among
regular household objects
and you solve them by arranging items in
a very particular way
[Music]
many of the levels have multiple
solutions
it's all about observation
and imagining the different structures
that could be at play
the game takes inspiration from our own
home
[Music]
and some of our own little tendencies
another big source of inspiration for
the game is our cat rookie
who should be around here somewhere
[Music]
occasionally this cat will show up on
the periphery of your gameplay
and undo your tidy work
just to shake things up a little bit
the game starts off pretty simple
but as you progress the logic behind the
puzzles becomes a little more
surreal
[Music]
there is a lot to tidy up in a little to
the left
actually every day brings something new
[Music]
with the daily tidy delivery
you get even more out of our favorite
puzzles
[Music]
and you earn fun badges too
[Music]
well thanks for stopping by
we hope you enjoy a little to the left
when it releases later this year
see you later bye
[Music]
i've been excited about this one ever
since it was announced ages ago it's
from developer gummy cat it's called
bear and breakfast and the title says it
all you're a bear you run in bed and
breakfast in the woods and it's really
freaking fun we're debuting a brand new
animated trailer a bunch of gameplay
you've never seen and finally announcing
a release date
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm iona and i'm radish we're from gummy
cat in romania today we're showing you
our first game called bear and breakfast
it's a laid back management adventure
game where you build and run a b b in
the woods but you're a bear
[Music]
in bear and breakfast you play as hank
a young curious bear from silver valley
who lives in a small home with his mom
and two best friends
[Music]
we grew up on management sims
games like theme hospital were big
inspirations for us but we also wanted
to make a game that tells a story
alongside the usual management stuff
[Music]
so it turns out that humans are coming
back for some reason and they need a
place to stay there's old rundown
buildings all over the place and you're
just the bear for the job
[Music]
the game follows a linear story that you
advance by solving quests
a lot of them involve finding materials
building rooms crafting furniture and
decorating stuff
[Music]
the actual furniture you do make awards
different kinds of points for instance
beds give comfort showers give hygiene
that type of thing
you have to make sure that your room
scores are high enough to satisfy
whatever your guests are asking for
[Music]
each type of score comes with its own
challenges for example later on you'll
need to cook food for your guests
through a mini game
[Music]
there's a lot more to bearing breakfast
but you can play at your own pace since
the game won't rush you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh and there's definitely no creepy
subplot hidden somewhere in the forest
[Music]
we're very excited to be part of day of
the devs this year and we can't wait to
introduce you all to hank and his
friends when baron breakfast launches
later this summer
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
so i don't want to say a lot about this
next one uh it's full of secrets and
puzzles and mystery that are best
discovered on your own it's a beautiful
game from a studio called shared memory
it's a
pixel art metroidvania full of
interesting creatures it's called animal
well
hi i'm billy basso today i'm going to be
showing you a game i've been working on
called animal well
[Laughter]
in animal well you explore a surreal
and sometimes dangerous pixel art
labyrinth
that is filled with secrets
[Music]
as you explore you'll encounter
various creatures but it's not always
clear if they're friendly or not so
it's best to
proceed with some amount of caution
[Music]
[Music]
throughout the game you're gonna find
various items that will
give you new abilities and help yourself
some puzzles
[Music]
every item in the game has multiple uses
but you're going to have to experiment
if you want to figure out what they all
are
[Music]
[Music]
animal well is a pixlr game
that's not just a pander to nostalgia
instead i'm viewing as a technical
opportunity a 4k tv screen has 144 times
as many pixels but
that means i have 144 times as much
processing power to apply to each pixel
throughout the game you'll see a lot of
things like fluid sims or dynamic
lighting effects that haven't really
been used in a pixar game before
[Music]
designing animal law is a layered
experience so what that means is the
base layer is something the average
person can play through and enjoy to
completion
but then there's a second layer which
for most games you would consider this
part like 100 in the game
there are lots of hidden items uh in
nooks and crannies throughout the world
they're not obvious and they you might
need some help to find these
the third layer has puzzles that don't
really present themselves as puzzles
they might go unnoticed for years
potentially or they might require some
community collaboration to solve
also there's a
there's a puzzle in this video
that may require some community
collaboration to understand but
the first 10 people to
figure it out um we'll get a free copy
of the game at launch
and then while you're doing that you can
maybe wish list it
uh
yeah thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
next up is nyad a colorful exploration
game where you play as a water nymph
traversing a zen and peaceful world this
game comes to us from high warp a solo
developer from spain
hi i'm really happy to be part of the
10th anniversary of the other days at
this exciting summerfest video i'm
melvin from highward i saw the video
studio from spain working on bringing to
life with unique personal games
i would like to say we do appreciate
when i had a relaxing and qualified
exploration event about flowing by a
river
i put all my love creating every part of
this game so please enjoy
[Music]
so
[Music]
the journey starts with the birth of a
little water leaf at the spring of the
river nya will grow up a matter of time
in vitality from floating legs and
flowers
learning to swim like a dark dive like a
fish
dust like a frog
finding other other rubber friends like
butterflies rabbits snakes turtles
coconut rice and much more
help them to find their way avoiding
obstacles and dangers using your skills
you will immerse through a lot of
beautiful places like a deep forest
a dark cave
a youthful creek
and more
water symbolizing life is that pure and
fresh
and little by little it will be fading
into dark you can seem to regenerate the
natural making sprout flowers in the
path
and you must do your best because the
humans
are controlling this river goal
humans create their own fake rivers like
these nice roads with strange smoke
creatures
you are the guardian of this river and
that seemed to be a difficult task but
don't be afraid because a tiny cloud
will take care of you from the sky
the beautiful hair of naya is like its
vitality you can make it grow up under
the sunrise change its color even tie
small flowers on it
creating a yacht i focus it on a whole
zone experience
enjoy it at your own pace exploring and
flowing there will be available for pc
and consoles by the end of this year
thank you for watching
[Music]
if you ever find yourself longing for
the good old days then why not take a
trip back to the stone age in this
cooperative life and farming simulation
game from soderden and cryptico hunt and
gather to care for your settlement
explore the ancient world around you and
best of all become a friend to the
mammoths this is roots of pacha
hi i'm timo co-founder of soledan along
with my brother
hi i'm karen the narrative designer
we're based in san diego with the rest
of the team in argentina hola todos i am
dancer the main artist and i'm johnny
timo's brother we are the team
developing roots of pacha a farming
scene set in the stone age where you
help your clan develop the ideas that
shape humanity
[Music]
in a time when there weren't stores to
buy seeds or anything else you'll build
your village from the ground up
[Music]
instead of using money you'll transform
the world around you by contributing and
working with your clan
starting small you'll explore the
regions of this new land discovering
plants and resources along the way
[Music]
many of the ideas you developed were the
cornerstones of early civilizations like
farming domesticating animals and the
creation of tools that are now common
ideas will build on one another and
after a while you'll find your community
transformed
[Music]
[Music]
you'll venture into the caves to meet
the spiritual world to try and explain
who you are and why you're here
the game's stoneage setting was inspired
by the book the clan of the cave bear
rootsapacha is set in simpler times but
the society is still complex
example finding something to eat went
from satisfying a basic need to making a
dish and creating a reason to gather
[Music]
as you discover ways to make life easier
you'll find time to experience all the
fun poaches world has to offer
[Music]
you'll get to know your clan meet others
living around you and maybe even find
that special someone
our love of farming sims started with
the first harvest moons and sardi valley
took it to the next level
with roots of pacha we want to make our
own unique contribution to this genre
we're working on this project with all
of our hearts we're super excited for
you to play the final version in the
meantime we have a brand new demo that
just went live today thanks for having
us
[Music]
but
[Music]
and now i am very pleased to present a
world premiere from our friends at us
two games the folks who brought you
monument valley alba and a bunch of
other really really cool games
here it is
[Music]
at those two games we really try and
take what's meaningful and great about
games and deliver that to everybody so
with monument valley we make people care
about a character for the first time if
they've never really engaged with games
very much and with alba wildlife
adventure we took open world games and
packaged that into a kind of theme about
saving an island that more people are
going to want to engage with than just
the hardcore and with this game what we
really want to do is take these genres
that we really love like roguelike games
and turn-based tactics add a little bit
of sports game in there as well and
themes about dreams and conflicting
fears and really package that together
into something that feels really unique
in the game you play the role of dester
he's a young person in their early 20s
he's coming home for the first time
having not left home in their the very
best way their relationship with their
mother and their family and their
friends there's a few of them that were
a little bit broken and they were broken
because they didn't really have the
words to say and their father who used
to be a big part of their life
unfortunately passes away and they don't
have those tools and that person to lean
on to to bridge that gap
so they managed to go home they found
this old ball they used to play with
their dad and when they try and fall
asleep with it they find themselves in a
world between worlds neither asleep nor
awake and when they're in this they can
explore these moments these memories and
solve these creative problems through a
through a ball game and when they do
that they find the right words to say to
confront these people
the people we're going to be meeting in
dustin's dreams are people who were
significant to testa before they left
town a couple of years back
and there are lots of people they don't
know quite as well too
and some people who have been shaped by
desta's impression of them in their
dreams but they've all had profound
impact on desta's life
these characters are really interesting
because all of them are interwoven as
part of justice story but also with each
other
they don't just appear as abstractions
but they really feel like a part of the
makeup of dusta's background
one way or another the people that
destiny throughout the game helped us to
become who they are today and they've
taught us to a number of different
things like standing up for themselves
taking risks expressing themselves and
more there are a few different themes in
the story but i would say that certainly
loss is a big part of it
finding yourself courage and
perseverance and free reawakening no pun
intended
it feels like we've been able to put a
lot of our ourselves into desta um the
same is true for pretty much all of our
games but dester in particular is very
personal to a lot of the members of the
team um i'm sure we can all relate to
some of the themes of maybe having
ghosted a friend and not being sure how
you could like get back in touch with
them or
dwelling over how you might have said
something in a conversation and like
having that play over and over in your
mind which is like one of the core
themes of the game it's definitely got
more depth and more game mechanics than
anything we've made before and it's
being designed from the ground up to be
a multi-platform title we're really
looking forward to telling you more
about destro the memories between in the
coming weeks and the coming months
[Music]
this next game is called shim it's a
shadow platformer you're a little blobby
character platforming around inside
shadows and a game with a really cool
minimalist graphic art style i hope you
like it
hi i'm about and i'm the developer of
skip and i'm nils from exonyx and i help
avo develop skim we're located in the
north of the netherlands in a town
called leoware we are a team of two plus
the talented people at moon celebrity
audio
[Music]
[Music]
same as a game where you move around in
shadows
you play as a shrimp a shadow creature
[Music]
as a whole stream is made to be
approachable for a variety of players at
its core it's about jumping around the
shadows and platforming towards the end
of the level
[Music]
each shadow has our own skin
[Music]
the player plays around as a scream of a
human however this team is separated
from that person and it's up to you to
find your way back
[Music]
in the game you will also help other
stem characters who have also been
separated on their shadow
you can help them by finding their
objects
skimp takes big inspiration from the
feeling of playing as a child
playing imaginary games with made-up
rules move around in shadows and jump to
the next shadow
[Music]
check it out and follow us at
shrimpgame.com
[Music]
hi everyone and thank you davda that's
driving us this year i'm and the manager
of asubu a community hub for indie game
creators in tokyo we have a space where
people can come to work and meet other
people do small gatherings and we are
helping japanese dev by introducing them
to platforms console publishers helping
them on marketing or as usually they
don't speak english helping them to
apply to overseas events like this one
and we're also doing a lot of online
contents and streams
like our big associate showcase which
will be aired this summer in english in
japanese or a monthly stream in the
collection and podcasts and many other
things you can check on youtube and
twitch
but first let's check two really cool
japanese titles
[Music]
[Applause]
fox and truck travelers the demand of
arashino island is a 3d action adventure
game with a japanese-inspired atmosphere
you will play as fox her girl will find
herself on arashino island and starts
travelling with frog
[Music]
tarry gates fustol lantern and neon
gives light and color to the island but
something is lurking in the shadows
inching even clogger
[Applause]
[Music]
fox and frog travelers is developed by
rheas an illustrator and concept artist
that came up with the idea for it based
on one of his illustrations
[Music]
fox and frog long journey through the
night is planned for release in a few
years
[Music]
first game of the young solo developer
yo fuji goodbye world is a narrative
game about two young in-game creators
the shaikhani and the extrovert comedy
[Music]
mixing influences from comics like ghost
world and games like the beginner's
guide or mozzare3
goodbye world is a tale about the
passion and struggles that comes with
game creation
through 13 chapters of the story
rendered in beautiful pixel art in a
resolution close to the super ness and
gameboy advance
[Music]
goodbye world is you out on steam later
this year if you like this game don't
hesitate to wishlist and you follow the
debt on twitter and if you are
interested by uh japanese indie scene or
indie games uh you can follow us on
twitter on discord chat with us and
watch our indie game showcase which is
uh coming this summer
and thank you again for watching and day
of the describing us
[Music]
the process of moving to a new city can
be daunting our next game birth from
solo developer madison carr who hails
from chicago explores the idea of
quelling loneliness through this puzzle
adventure
hi my name is madison and i'm making a
game called birth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
birth is a point-and-click puzzle game
about living alone in a large city
[Music]
in order to quell your loneliness you
decide to create a creature a friend a
partner for yourself by collecting spare
bones and organs that you find while
traversing the city
[Music]
you will explore libraries and post
offices and museums and cafes and
apartments that don't belong to you
in each of these buildings you will meet
creatures and you will get to know them
by searching through their personal
belongings
their laptops and phones their cabinets
and their notebooks
[Music]
within these personal belongings there
are puzzles
some are physics-based some are
pattern-based
some are abstract
there are no instructions and you are
rarely doing the same thing twice
[Music]
alongside the main game there are
optional hidden tokens that you can find
to unlock secret buildings and treasures
birth comes out this august i made this
game with my whole heart and i hope that
you like it
[Music]
in our next title how to say goodbye you
play as the ghost of a person who's
recently died and is embarking on the
journey of accepting their own death
the mechanics underscore the message
that there's always a way through grief
you may get stuck but you can always
stop re-evaluate and keep moving
it's all just part of the puzzle
hi i'm florian co-author of the upcoming
narrative puzzle game how to say goodbye
so
[Music]
in how to say goodbye you help a group
of quirky ghosts overcome various
obstacles and conundrums by reorganizing
the level as you like
[Music]
moving one tile we'll also push the
surrounding tiles
[Music]
the puzzle elements are only moved
around but never removed so just like a
rubik's cube the puzzles never end up in
a state where you can't solve them
[Music]
follow various characters looking to
discover why they are still here and how
to move on while trying to escape the
grasp of an evil wizard who doesn't know
how to let go
[Music]
to say goodbye tells a story of loss and
grief but we intend the experience to be
as gentle kind and positive as possible
if this sounds like something that you
would be interested in
please wishlist the game it would mean a
lot to us thank you
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
hi
well wasn't that a great show and a
great cake and it's all gone and so now
we have to say goodbye i hope you liked
that i hope you liked all the games
thank you to all the developers
for making such fantastic games and for
bringing them here for everyone to enjoy
special thanks to all of our generous
sponsors you've always been there for us
and we could not do this without you
playstation idea xbox nintendo
steam epic game store y'all are awesome
thank you extra special thanks to dos
one the magic man for supplying all the
beats and sound effects and tunes you
hear in every summer game fest edition
of day of the devs
we couldn't have done any of this
without you
or at least it'd be really quiet uh and
kind of suck we're not done with the day
of the dev 10th anniversary just yet if
you go to day of thedevs.com and sign up
for our newsletter you will be amongst
the first to hear about all the
excitement that's to come this year uh
other than that thank you so much to
everybody who watched and we'll see you
next year bye
we'll see you next time aha you thought
it was over but it is actually not day
the devs continues with a special
after-party performance by the one and
only peter berkman of onomato fame he's
debuting new music from a game you've
probably never heard of it's called
little nemo and the guardians of
slumberland and the reason you haven't
heard of it is because it's debuting on
kickstarter at this
very freaking moment
enjoy see you later thanks for tuning in
to day of the devs summer game fest
edition bye